Mit erhobenen Händen rannten die Schüler
am Mittwoch über das Gelände einer High
School in Parkland im US-Bundesstaat Florida.
Zuvor hatte hier ein 19-jähriger ehemaliger
Schüler um sich geschossen und mindestens
17 Menschen getötet.
Die Schüsse aus einem Sturmgewehr fielen
kurz vor Schulschluss und lösten Panik unter
Hunderten von Schülern aus.
Die meisten Opfer wurden im Schulgebäude
erschossen.
Es handelt sich sowohl um Schüler als auch
um Erwachsene.
Der 19-jährige Täter ließ sich nach Behördenangaben
widerstandslos festnehmen.
Er sei erst vor kurzem aus disziplinarischen
Gründen der Schule verwiesen worden, sagte
Sheriff Scott Israel.
"Er ist in Haft.
Wir haben damit begonnen, uns die Webseiten,
die er besucht hat und seine Aktivitäten
in sozialen Netzwerken anzusehen.
Einige Dinge dort sind sehr verstörend."
Eltern durften ihre Kinder inzwischen von
der Schule abholen.
Viele stehen unter Schock:
"Ich war im ersten Stock des Gebäudes und
er ist über den Gang gelaufen.
Er hat in die Klassenräume geschossen.
Auch durch meine Tür."
"Er war im dritten Stock, er kannte sich in
der Schule aus.
Er wusste, wo die Leute waren.
Er war vorbereitet."
Beschreibungen der Schüler zufolge soll der
Schütze ein Einzelgänger mit Faible für
Schusswaffen und Messer sein.
Unter einer Gasmaske geschützt, habe er Rauchbomben
gezündet.
US-Präsident Donald Trump sprach den Angehörigen
der Opfer seine Anteilnahme aus.
"Kein Kind, Lehrer oder überhaupt jemand
sollte sich jemals in einer amerikanischen
Schule gefährdet fühlen", schrieb er auf
Twitter.